he's sick
he's sick as a dog
yes he's very sick that's why he's up
today he
i was told he's sick not eating he's
puking you want me to go into the whole
tire tread as far as what happened today
with him
so we can get that speculation done with
as far as that he's going to be moved
he shot his pants he was puking he was
doing everything
john tortorella telling it like it is we
always use a clip like that when it's
time to set up one of our favorite
segments of the week airing of
grievances just because the football
season has ended the grievances continue
chris as always now i don't know how
many grievances you're going to have
after spending the whole week on the
beach yeah but maybe you've been back
long enough that you got something
that's got you lathered up yeah i don't
have a ton uh that that is getting at me
right now you know it takes a lot to
rile me up i think the first thing is
this and i'm gonna go with le'veon bell
because this is another subject just
annoyed me uh throughout the weeks the
last few weeks especially when i go on
other radio stations or things
throughout the country mike le'veon bell
for some reason gets lumped in the into
the oh he's a pain in the butt type of
player himself like antonio brown and
he's part of the issues there in
pittsburgh steelers and i think that i
just want to stop that narrative because
i think that's ridiculous you know we
can't get mad at le'veon bell for using
a tool in which uh was completely within
his right to do to
guarantee himself future guaranteed
money and security for his family and
even the next generation of his family
he he wasn't being a bad guy he's never
been an issue yes i know he smoked weed
in a car a few years ago oh my gosh
that's the worst thing we've ever seen
okay but although who among us hasn't
done that raise your hand right i mean i
know you do that on a daily basis hot
boxing cards i'm not talking about me
but regardless
but regardless i don't like how he gets
lumped in that conversation because one
i've been around le'veon bell he's about
as nice as they come as far as being a
good guy and being a nice guy he is
loved by his teammates there in
pittsburgh and i just don't want to get
him lumped in there with oh he's a diva
pain in the butt star football player
because he's not he just made an
incredibly tough business decision this
year and i just don't like that along
with the franchise tag in general that's
almost i want to do a double grievance
there but uh i do think le'veon bell
kind of gets a a bad rap because he's on
the steelers and he held out and he's
friends with antonio brown and they get
lumped together and i just don't think i
i like that well i'm going to kind of
take the baton over this one because i
agree with what you're saying and i want
to expand on it because the reason
le'veon bell ultimately sat out all of
2018 and and held out until right before
the start of the 2017 season is because
the steelers never made him the kind of
long-term offer that he was comfortable
signing they used the franchise tag to
keep him off the market to keep him from
getting the maximum payday but they
didn't want to use that franchise tag as
the true starting point for a long-term
deal they didn't want to guarantee money
beyond the first year this is one of my
problems with the steelers they have all
these rules that are separate and apart
from the rules of the cba that they
constantly force upon their players we
will have no negotiations once the
season begins we won't redo your
contract if there's more than one year
left unless you're a quarterback and we
won't have any guaranteed money beyond
the first year of the deal well maybe
you should and maybe if you had le'veon
bell would still be on your team so
don't blame him when you're going to use
the weapons available to you and you're
going to add some yeah of your own
artificial rules don't get pissed off
when the player decides you know what
you're going to treat it like a business
i'm going to treat it like a business
right and this gets back to one of the
things that drives me crazy when the
owners make true business oh yes say
titan of industry congratulations when a
player does it he's selfish he's not a
team player he's a no good piece of crap
on and on and that drives me crazy when
players act like businessmen they get
criticized because god forbid a player
exercises his prerogative to change
teams yeah well i mean you know and to
your point which you know i agree with a
hundred percent i mean where was the
complaints about you know arthur blank
or the owner of the buffalo bills they
cut charles clay and robert alford they
still had years left on their contract
why didn't they honor their contract you
know that is a part of yes me as a fan
me as an ex player that i don't
understand even when i go work out at
the gym i still have people say that
well these players don't honor their
contract and i have to tell gentlemen
like hey but you don't ever say that
when it's vice versa when the team cuts
ties with the player so yes that hang on
i would love to be there while you're
arguing with some meat head yeah about
players no i just that would be great
can you take like a gopro or something
just call me big chest chris sims okay
all right i'm sorry to interrupt you i
just couldn't resist this image this
image of you going nose to nose with the
you know with gino from jersey is just
something that i couldn't ignore no
that's okay i don't i don't ever get
nose-to-nose i'm always open for
conversation i think you know i'm a
pretty good guy but i go through periods
of the gym where i don't get much done
because people just keep talking to me
about football so that's one of the
struggles of my life is it your
grievance next or is it mine here
i don't know what was yours well go
ahead and let me go and then you kind of
went off of it i didn't know if that was
go ahead go ahead throw something else
on the fire my other grievance is with
you specifically first of all you look
very handsome in your black shirt today
i really like the look it's good it's
blue oh is it blue okay either way i
like you would it be better if i
buttoned it all the way to the top of
course it would you'd be cool but either
way uh my other is is something that i
saw yesterday on the site because i live
on pro football talking about as much as
you but i'm on there a lot no indication
of anyone making a move to sign caller
kaepernick give it up mike it's not
gonna freaking happen he's not gonna get
signed by anybody in any league at any
time it is over i'm sorry to say that i
like colin kaepernick a lot and i am all
for his cause and what he's fighting for
because he's right there but
man you look funny with those glasses on
but regardless
yes give it up on the colin kaepernick
thing it's not gonna happen
now if you had read the whole article
you would have realized that was kind of
my point okay good i didn't read the
whole article this time yeah
my point is you got mark garrigus on cnn
boy this is really cool you look at mark
on cnn
saying that again and he keeps making
these bold predictions i hope he never
gambles any money on any of his
predictions but he made the bold
prediction somebody's going to sign him
in the next three weeks i don't think
it's going to happen that was the gist
of the story so uh my my grievance is
now with you you're going to call me out
without reading my story well i've read
this story so many times okay good thank
you finally so it's over i believe it's
over when you start writing stop writing
posts about it you know and then i'll
know it's over but for now you're still
on like a
every other day post something about
kaepernick type thing so i just i had to
point that out first of all it's the
offseason and second of all
he's kind of in the news right now he
just settled his grievance with the nfl
last week and oh by the way nike's got
this new jersey this this drives me
crazy yeah this disconnect between nike
which is the apparel provider for the
nfl right they're selling a black and
white kaepernick jersey it's already
sold out
and and they are firmly in the pro
cabinet camp and the nfl is firmly in
the anti-kaepernick camp but it's not
going to change and i i just that
disconnect i i don't understand it but i
just think that's reality and and off we
go yep that's it yup all right i got i
think i got one more good
and and this uh i i don't
i kind of have a grievance with brown's
fans who have been giving me the
business for the last three weeks i was
on radio in cleveland yesterday and and
they kind of they kind of set me up for
this they didn't tell me that they were
going to come at me right out of the
gates with this but any time the
interview starts with i have a bone to
pick with you oh yeah my first
inclination is to just hang up the phone
i think that should be everybody should
start the conversation like that with
you that would be pretty foolproof
i was on weei in boston super bowl week
and
we we were talking about the seth
wickersham story about the dysfunction
in cleveland yeah
and um
my take on it is that baker mayfield is
smart enough to sense if there really is
dysfunction in cleveland and you know
what baker mayfield may be a member of a
new breed that decides
i'm going to play out my rookie contract
and you can tag me once you can tag me
twice you can tag me three times and i
think the cba at best it's an open
question whether or not you can ever tag
a guy a fourth time but you know for
non-quarterbacks by the time you play
that out you're in your 30s for
quarterbacks who cares hey i'm 30 31 i'm
still in my prime i'm just starting my
prime see you later and browns fans went
nuts on me for pointing out that if
baker mayfield thinks that it's better
for his career long term if the
ownership of the browns is an impediment
to him being as good as he can be to the
team being as good as it can be what if
he decides i'm never signing a long-term
deal i'm going to i'm going to honor my
contract i'm gonna be here in cleveland
and the moment that i can get to the
open market i'm going and i know that
browns fans still have that raw nerve
after lebron james left twice
but i i just feel like after we saw kirk
cousins tremaine johnson le'veon bell to
a certain extent antonio brown another
guy we're going to be talking about in
the next segment i think at some point
these young guys coming in are going to
have that nba mentality where i'm going
to put in my time under this rookie deal
and then i'm out of here yeah i i think
you're right about that i do think it's
a new wave and a new age as far as
player information and what they know
and and knowing how to play the the
business game of the nfl a little bit
more and baker mayfield hey i mean you
know i think he's one of these rare guys
that can get the dysfunction out of an
organization to a degree you know i i
hope that doesn't happen the the thing
you're talking about but you're right i
don't think he's the type of player that
if he felt like things were never going
to get fixed in cleveland he wouldn't be
scared to do it but i also think one of
the reasons you wanted to talk about
baker mayfield as being rookie of the
year right over saquon barkley which is
a very close race was you felt like he
was turning around just the perceived
notion of that organization right what
he's doing he kind of you know got the
hugh jackson dysfunction out of there
coaches who are really good coaches
around the league want to go to
cleveland because they know how special
of a guy and a leader and a player he is
so uh it is sometimes
you know once in a every 10 years and
type of thing where a guy like this can
come into organization and truly turn it
around because of his attitude and his
talent and his day-to-day charisma and
baker seems to have that
the question is how much better would
the team be if it didn't have
dysfunction at the very top that's the
thing that i think baker mayfield is
going to be very astute he's going to
talk to people he's going to do his
research and before he ever puts his
name on his second contract he's going
to want to believe that it truly has
turned around top to bottom and clear
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports